Just give me a moment.
Shhh.
They're good.
And...
They're there.
I know this is a rather interesting concept.
So please be relieved to know that any bit that occurs between us is deeper, okay?
You don't have to worry.
I would never do anything to hurt or harm you.
And the effects are gonna wear off after two hours.
Take away this and maybe even less for the effects, cause when I bring you back up, you'll remember.
But just let it up.
I'm gonna bring you deep down with me.
Now, for the interesting question, I'd like for you to ponder my darling.
You've been called one name your entire life, haven't you?
Do you think you're susceptible enough to forget that name for a small amount of time?
And maybe I can replace it?
It's okay, it's just something to think about, to ponder in your mind,
to imagine that I could see a fancy mix of words that would make you fall.
You'd fail to recall something you may consider so important.
It is your name after all, and your name means you, of course.
But there's another name that I like.
It's Riefling.
It's why I like to call you for a little while.
But the problem is you may not respond in the way I want you to, or the way I would like you to.
And you may not realize why it means so much to me.
Hypnosis interests me, and it makes me excited at the same time.
At the prospect of playing with you, to have you just the way I want, even if it's for a little while.
Some days giving up control can feel good, and I hope I can earn your trust if I haven't already with my reassurance.
If that sounds like something you'd like to do with me, I'd really appreciate it.
It's okay to be apprehensive or worry if it's gonna work or not.
If not, instead just use this day to relax and gently take a moment for yourself.
Are you okay?
Good.
Then, now you can close your eyes, or you can focus on me.
Some people describe them as quite tantalizing, almost hard to look away from.
Not in a strange way, but rather a soothing way.
Like when you look into the flames of a fire, and it feels like your pupils are dilated.
That kind of trance you enter when focusing deep on something, but letting your senses go and start slowly ignoring the outside world.
I want to show you that this is all very okay.
I can be as slow as you need.
I think it's important to know what you're getting into.
Enter the idea that you may be slowly falling deeper into trance.
As if I was a fire dancing before your eyes.
Exit instead of an energetic burst of rain, please.
Crackling and popping, I am a small, smoldering fire.
I am warmth that can radiate gently against your skin, against your face.
I am gentle, quiet, soothing, relaxing.
You might even feel the warmth all over.
Can you imagine it now for me?
The warmth radiating from me onto your face, and then slowly down your neck,
past your shoulders, then equally turn your arm to your elbow.
Your wrists until your hands are warm, it's not hot, it's a comfort sensation.
I already ate more.
Past your shoulders, turn your abdomen, to your stomach, then turn further to your hips.
And again, that heat will equally split down your legs.
You're tied to your calves and down to your feet.
It feels like an embrace.
I want to embrace you.
Both body and mind, at the same time.
Would you let me in?
Would you let yourself be open to what I offer?
Maybe you think to yourself, should I resist?
But then why would you want to?
It's so warm, and the rain here, eager and waiting.
You love it to please others, and this would please me.
Unless...
What's this?
Are you not able to think so clearly anymore to yourself?
That's alright, that's okay.
That makes me happy that you're made to slowly switch off.
It's not fast, like a late switch, no.
It takes time to let your brain go to sleep and be open to me.
Just like a smoldering fire gives you warmth.
That warmth slowly takes over until you may experience the pleasurable sensation of not forming a thought at all.
Just listening to my voice, letting me take over slowly.
There's no rush, just you and me together going on this journey.
If you could resist, you might be saying, what would it be like if you went under?
And having me be the one in control of you.
You know you can go even deeper with me.
I think we would both enjoy, and you'd find the pleasure of all.
I think it would be worth every second that you're under.
The good thing is, you don't have to think, you just have to let it happen to you.
That's right, very good.
Let me fully embrace your mind.
Deeper and deeper, you'll know that only my voice remains in your head.
Just look at me and forget it all.
You are safe, you are loved, and by the day I finish it with you, you'll already want to go again.
Down, down, down you go.
Deeper and deeper and deeper, just like whatever happens happens.
Either way, you will be relaxed by the end of it.
I want to get there, and by the end, you'll be main, okay?
Three, any voices get quieter until it's just made you hear.
Two, the warmth fully taken over your body, you just accept.
One, as you now give up and offer no resistance at all.
Zero, you are main, my darling.
My voice, always with you, and gating you steadily through all of this.
You're doing fantastic, you really are, and you're making me so happy right now.
You know, how desirable it is for me to see that black expression of yours, right?
How precious it is.
But we have a slight, small situation, don't we?
I need you to learn your name.
Yes, you are clean, blank, slate-ragena, with no name at all.
It's forgotten, and you have let me assign you a name.
A beautiful name that lets everyone know what an amazing man you are,
and that you are owned by me, and it's okay of that illicit response.
I encourage it.
Your name is Riefling.
Riefling, Riefling, Riefling, Riefling.
But why, mistress, why is this name important?
Don't worry, I'll answer the questions you might have if you could think right now.
My precious little Riefling.
Riefling to me means unwavering loyalty that we show to one another.
The kindness of two souls connect in any way we can,
whether for a passing moment or for an insatiable bond.
The love that is shared between mistress and Riefling cannot be recreated elsewhere.
It's what we have together.
Isn't that right, Riefling?
Don't you hate it for me?
Good Riefling.
You make me so happy when you're in this state.
Oh, darling, do you remember that war and embrace from the smoldering fire earlier?
That's our love we share for one another, which we can ignite it and bring flames for an even warmer embrace.
And I assure you, it's good.
The flames can hurt us.
Only have a burning desire for more.
Maybe deep down, you can't wait for me to be in control again, alright?
Even though you're under it right now, the desire for me to reassure you,
you will always be mine to look after, and you will never be a burden to me.
I accept you from all your flaws, just as you accept me from mine.
The embrace that you feel is unwavering love and is all around us.
Sometimes it's harder to fade, but you will always have a place with me.
I wish that life could be gentle and escaped as we are to one another,
but you will never feel sheep for desire or for yearning when it roped me.
I may be in control of you, Refling, but I serve you.
This is not one side.
This is not me over you.
This is us, my darling Refling.
And I want to plant a small seed of influence, one of confidence that I know you deserve.
Imagine in front of us a soil patch next to the warm fire that dances before our eyes.
We're on our knees before each other, looking into one another's eyes.
I open my hand before you to reveal a seed.
You take it from my hand and plant it without a word.
I would ask you if you know what you've done, but you don't have the words for them right now.
And that's okay.
You just know you've done the right thing and made me happy.
That seed can be nurtured over time, but you have to be the one to water it.
Because once it grows, not only is it a symbol of what we have done for one another,
but you can be proud of it.
You can be boastful.
You can think yourself having a second wind of confidence that you are my Refling.
And you have nothing to apologize for.
I love you.
There's just one thing though, Refling.
I know your pain is easy, and it's hard to remember all the details other than what I say to you.
But don't worry, that's good.
I want to explain a bit more about myself, about my desires.
Why I want this from you.
I want to be in control of you, even if for a little time.
It makes me feel powerful.
It makes me happy to think a grown man like yourself is drooling and waiting for the next command to leave my life.
I want to care for you when you're in such a wonderful state like this for me.
Maybe I'm the only one who's ever gone to you like this before.
That would make me very happy.
And keep the big secret of what you like.
I won't shave you, I won't dull you or be mean.
I'd love to tease you though.
Maybe one day I should suggest body paralysis and try to instruct you to do certain things with me.
That kind of mean teasing is just one for me to consider right now.
But in the future, if you go under by me again, then maybe I can give you special kinds of rewards.
But for now, we have to be proper.
You know how to behave, right?
Like a good dog, a good little loyal wreathling for your mistress.
Good boy.
I love that my words alone could get you into such a deep trap.
That warm feeling still all over you.
Maybe it's even tingly.
I'd like that if you could both relax and have your night played with at the same time.
I know I should.
But your name is wreathling right now.
So I won.
I basted you, but in a good way.
Should you fight me, next day I try to put you under.
Could you imagine the fun of having days I would get with you?
I can imagine it.
Can you?
I would climb on top of you, look you deep in your eyes.
You wouldn't be allowed to break eye contact, but you can feel the weight of my body against yours.
The warmth radiating again.
War, war, war.
It's all too much to resist.
It's all you can think about.
I place a sensation as the coziness it offers.
The comfort of the smoothness that can be yours if you just give it.
You wouldn't say no to me wreathling.
I already do so much for you.
My words are good, but my actions are even bitter, aren't they?
Yes, they were certainly on.
Can you gently drop deeper for me?
Good, I want your brainless.
The only thing you know right now is my voice, and that your name is wreathling.
You belong to me, and everything feels amazing.
I think it's time to reward your subconscious too.
I have to train every layer of your brain.
An intimate experience between you and I.
The warmth of the fire doesn't dissipate,
but I can help you cool down a little.
I can help you cool down a little.
It doesn't dissipate, but I can help you cool down a little.
You never have to think again when you're with me.
Come brainless with me.
Relax.
Let the numbness take over completely.
You're safe.
You're accepted.
You're with me wreathling, and you're my responsibility to take care of.
Relax.
Let yourself space up.
Ape the head.
No thoughts.
Just me and you.
Shhh.
It's okay wreathling.
You can let go.
You don't have to hold on anymore.
Let me take over.
Let me be in charge, and make the decisions.
Let me make it easier for you.
You can let go.
It's okay.
I'm here with you.
Let go.
Allow yourself to drift with me.
It's okay.
Let me look after you.
Let me carry you.
You just remain brainless, and numb.
You just have to obey.
Obey wreathling.
You will obey me.
There is no resistance, only acceptance.
Deeper.
Shhh.
There.
Are you being conditioned? I wonder.
Am I getting deep into your mind?
Nothing happens now, and that's okay.
It's just me and my little wreathling.
It's a reward.
All this one-on-one attention.
If I did this, it shouldn't sell like you, but you need more.
Because when you crave it, I'll be here.
Obey wreathling to pamper you, over and over again, until you can't take it anymore.
And you're just my 24-7.
So deep that you can never fully go back.
Because I'll be there in the back of your mind,
encouraging you every step of the way, influencing your day-to-day life,
inspiring you to be the man I know you can be.
So be gained wreathling, because that's what you are.
A gained boy that deserves the world.
Let's keep you relaxed.
For a little bit longer, okay?
Repetition and hypnosis is really good.
I wonder if that works for ASMRtists when I do to you while you're like glass.
I wonder if you'd hear the trigger.
And think of me.
I'm not conditioning you, darling.
Maybe my little wreathling, you're conditioning yourself.
Does it save me with lots of different things?
Now that would be happy that you'd be so susceptible to whiteness.
That you could help yourself or stop your own mind.
My little wreathling.
Let yourself relive.
I give you permission to talk.
You're allowed to pleasure some blame.
You're allowed to enjoy what you want.
Okay.
Good boy.
Very good boy.
But I can't have you forever.
No one stays like this.
My little wreathling.
My little sleepy head.
I think it's tight.
I slowly and gently bring you back up.
Okay.
You're very deep right now with the ampers and the warmth.
So we can do this together.
Just listen to my voice and follow my instructions.
I'm going to get upwards from zero to three.
One, three, you will wake up.
Okay.
And I will be with you.
Every step of the way.
Alright.
It always works out in the end when we're together.
It's just one small thing.
I don't want you to remember the details of the session.
Clearly.
I think it would be more interesting
if your memory was positive but not quite clear in what we did together
or the things I said.
Is that alright wreathling?
Can I ask that of you?
I think secrecy in our sessions is good.
Even though it's a shame to know.
Remember all the love we shared when you're so wonderful with me.
Deep down you'll know.
Maybe another day might make something for you
and I'll permit you to remember it all.
You do still need my permission at the end of the day
and I wouldn't have it any other way.
If you want the effects to last
only respond to wreathling truly and wholeheartedly
and your name will come back in roughly two hours.
Your little secret.
Zero.
The embrace you feel from the fire
will still be inside you.
I'll always be with you
but you may be able to feel the sensation
slowly making its way back.
It feels less impactful
but not in a negative way
as the feeling reveres this
and makes its way up to your head
where it once started.
It's like a fog on your mind
is lending slowly
as if being blown away by the wind.
What?
You're aware that I'm talking to you
that I was able to get you very deep with me.
Your thoughts return too
although they are incredibly quiet
and my voice still takes precedence
over everything else.
You just need to come up, up, up, alright?
Keep doing it.
You're doing so well.
I know it's nice being under
but it's time to be brought up to consciousness.
Dude, you're with me, aren't you?
You're aware that you are under
but it's not quite clear
everything we did together
and that's okay, Refling.
I promise it was nothing bad
and I equally promise
that you did a great job for me
and I still get to go you, Refling.
Three, up, up, up
until you're back with me again.
Hi, Refling.
Hi, baby.
Hello.
Are you there?
Are you back today?
Hi.
Hi, baby.
Okay, bye.
Hopefully you have a nice warm, fuzzy feeling right now.
Well, I did need to spoil you lots of ASMR after came.
Baby.
Just so you know,
my little cutie pie
I have spent one hour roughly
that's past since we got started.
Okay.
Just so you know, Casey,
I know how much time passed, it's been one hour
but it's okay, baby.
My little Refling.
Okay, give me one second.
One, two, three, four.
Hi, baby.
Hi, cutie pie.
You did really well.
You did and it's true, you did, you did really, really well
and I'm very, very happy.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
I was struggling a little bit but thank you pulled through for me.
So I need to give you lots of cute after care with Tinka.
Wow, good job.
Hi, baby.
Hi.
Just relax a little bit, okay?
And if you need to hydrate, you can.
I'm happy to tingle you for a little bit longer.
You are publicist, I can be publicist.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm out.
Thank you.
Rock.
Let me tingle you so I can do the bubbles.
I don't know anything.
Let me say what I missed, okay?
Thank you, rock, rock, rock, rock,
rather than membership.
Thank Lord Weed Smash.
Real catmass, that was phenomenal, you like them.
I am glad.
A darling girlity, bubble-sense for you
and Matt 1618 for 150 gift.
Thank you so much.
All my babies.
I don't think I took you too deep this time, or I don't, maybe I did take you too, I don't
but if you want we can talk about more hypnosis ideas that you'd like to see, I thought about maybe, or maybe not, training you to be a dog
Ording, please, whoopsies, thank you again mother the gifted membership
Listerine, just trying to hate you, right?
Gracie, Jessie, thank you for the super chat, that was amazing, you liked it
Shhh
I'm definitely being super careful when I do this because I get so scared
Love is a bit too service level, let me ease into it, okay?
You're woofing orange, your head feels numb but a good gain, I'm glad
It should be numb rafeling, my job here is complete
No, I will not elaborate further, bye
Getting the papa, cheers his bark bark, I have not even drained you into my puppy yet
He wants to meet my little puppy, do you want me to put a little collar on you as well?
Ah, briefly, do it again
Oh, bye
I'll give your ears a little scratchy scratchy
Will you use a training clicker?
Ah, I should get one, I'ma miss you the fuck
Kill quick, thank you for the super chat, love in this stream
Strony is so glad, after a terrible week you got to rely
Thank you, mom, hello, thank you for the gifted, 50 members as well
Thank you, chokes on you, why did I stop you?
Shhh, shhh, shhh, shhh
One second, thank you so much, mom, hello for the gifted
One, cheers
Thank you so, so much and congrats to those god
This is just an aftercare session, okay?
Cause I gotta make sure you're okay
And you need to make sure you're hydrated too
Shhh, we found some
So the hypnosis sessions over, you can go back to the stream if you like the start
But this is the part where I take care of you
Cause it's not so easy
I can't put under make your brain or raise it
no over thinking
because I know what you're like refling you over think
which spank wopam
thank you Aleveevas
this was an amazing experience Ronnie
I still feel it in me brain
thank you mommy
you're welcome darling refling
are you cool?
very very shy
I just tinkle you gently
as you hear the most licks in the background
now you don't have to have to check
okay fine
shh shh shh shh
there
wow
Kalkar
thank you for the 50 gifted memberships as well
what the heck
thank you Matt 1680
thank you Momolo and Kalkar
and thank you
refling
for letting me play with you
I like having you in my hand
all malleable
and I get to do what I want with you
but that's the quiet part that comes later
here
I took beat up beyond your ears
did really well
do you think I can make good boy a trigger word?
good boy good boy good boy
all my refling is a good boy
and he makes me happy
he lets me play and tinkle him
and also take over his mind
you did really well on that session though
good boy makes you tingle
did so good
do it so so good
don't listen to the mask like this
shh shh shh shh
will there be more br...
refling
rye is done
yes when you put up like that
yes
there will be also hypnosis videos on my channel soon as well
you're gonna wall if you hear wall again
if you hear good boy
shh shh shh shh shh
there there
shh shh shh shh
hopefully you feel all tingly
and if I couldn't make you tingle
hopefully I made your pee pee tingle
I said
I said what others won't say
what you gonna do give me trouble
I mean I guess
yeah, it triggers your swallow reflex
do you know what that means?
it can mean that you're relaxed
or that you might be standing attention in response
you've been relaxing, I'm glad
I hope you feel a bit better, do you?
yeah
he done very well, yeah
I know some things getting into hypnosis can be a bit like, I don't know if it's safe or not, but it is
well, I hope I make it as safe as possible
so we can explore this together
because it is something new to explore
yeah
think a little bit longer
okay
give you some more tingly-wingelies
but as always, there's no lasting effects from this stream
a little bit of influence, but a fix, nyaw
I look after you
I hope you feel like I look after you anyway
that's my goal
they make you feel good
does that make you an influencer? it's over
got the cameras
lasting love for mommy, lasting love for replaying
hey
yeah
I'm gonna see if I can give you a hug or not, this is either gonna work or this is gonna sound really really silly, okay?
but I'm gonna hug the microphone, so come here you big cuddly teddy bear
I don't know, I have no idea what you can hear right now
but I'm giving you a big hug
you can't kiss a tag, come on
that's right, you can't keep up with a kiss-a-shot
I love you like
mommy baby
here we go
are you gonna be okay, sleepyhead?
cuz you aren't the only sleepyhead around here
bye bye
are you gonna be okay, replaying?
I'm gonna send you to another ASMR stream, okay?
I got less than two hours sleep, so
mommy isn't feeling too hot right now, Evelyn, sorry baby
I don't want you to worry though
I'll be okay
I'm gonna go and get a big sleep, okay?
I had to prepare a lot to put you under
it's a labor of love, they say
but I enjoy putting it together for you
I feel rewarded when you let go
so it's worth every second
8 minutes, 1-8
thank you, have a good rest, yeah
I'm gonna send you to another ASMR stream
with a polar bear, okay?
I'll look after you very shortly, okay?
love you, little replay
be kind to yourself, okay darling?
I love you
I'll dream about hypnotizing you, okay?
and all the fucked up scenarios I wanna do, do ya?
hmm
say hi to AC from me, okay?
bye baby
oh, you're lucky, you're lucky
I didn't know that, like, thank you for the extended membership
look into my small, refling eyes, you feeling going to sleep?
I'm gonna sleep, darling, I promise, okay?
say hi to AC from me
bye bye
bye